my name is george moats and it is my job
to preserve hamburger history what you
may or may not know is that there are
many many regional styles out there when
you get into the regional american
hamburger you're actually getting into
history and you're learning about where
these burgers come from in a way we're
actually learning all about who we are
as americans the cuban frita smoked
burger the green chili cheeseburger the
loco moco an original hamburger sandwich
ready to cook
let's do it
how about this one the cuban fritta to
me one of the greatest cuban american
gastronomic expressions the cuban fritos
alive and well in miami basically it's
an american hamburger with a lot of
spices inside the meat the beef is very
important in my recipe to two pounds of
ground beef i've added grated onion two
garlic cloves two tablespoons of paprika
some cumin pretty much the spices you'd
find in chorizo
just like in little havana they smash it
thin
they also add some onion right now
but once they smash thin they use this
red sauce on it check this out
that bubbles up all around it
patty comes off onto the cuban roll
follow me here ready for this one on top
of that
goes more onion these are deep-fried
julienned potatoes potato sticks
basically look at that one of the very
few burgers i'll actually have put
ketchup on
it's part of the experience
and it actually does work really well
with this and there it is that's the
cuban frittata
oh
that's good
good oh
whoa
oh good
next burger
on the topping speed round the green
chili cheeseburger whoa have you ever
had one they're incredible it's part of
pretty much every piece of new mexican
cuisine i like to say that jalapeno is
kind of like a
slap in the face and green chili is like
a
punch in the gut most people who eat
cheeseburgers in new mexico wouldn't
think of eating anything else but the
green chili cheeseburger most of the
flavor from a roasted green chili does
come from the roasting process because
it's very smoky these are really smoky
and very spicy
and they're very spicy and they do
release
a lot of
a lot of heat
[Music]
a little bit of salt green chili will
fall over the place what they do is they
actually put the green chili onto the
patty as it's cooking and then they
envelop
that green chili on the patty
with white american cheese
oh [ __ ]
oh yes
oh yeah
okay
you see this
wow
oh yeah that's perfect
there
oh the green chili cheeseburger
in my house
green chilies are hot obviously anytime
you eat spicy food it releases
endorphins when you're releasing
endorphins you feel kind of high so in a
way this burger kind of makes you high
it gives you a little buzz
[Laughter]
ah it's spicy that's very spicy the
smoked burger when you think about the
way a burger is normally cooked it's
usually cooked on a flat top something
that takes about five minutes smoking
usually takes a long time
hang on
whoa
oh [ __ ]
that come from
whoa
let's smoke a burger what i've done here
i've taken a classic backyard kettle
grill and i set it up for off set
smoking which basically means that i've
got coals on one side i'm going to put
the the burgers on the other side this
is going to sit here and smoke do you
want to know how long
50 minutes
the wood chips i use are mellow i don't
use hickory and mesquite you're much
better off using apple or elder woods
you don't want to overwhelm the flavor
of smoke
the key though is to make sure you keep
the smoke inside this thing 50 minutes
we're ready oh look at those oh yeah
i only put three things at a smoked
burger on a very uncomplicated squishy
roll
untoasted even first a slice of raw
onion in the bottom to protect the
bottom second put the patty
next i'm going to put the pickles on
dill pickle slices
and then
barbecue sauce any kind of barbecue
sauce
it's a smoked burger
smoke
that's ring good today i'm going to
teach you about a regional icon from
hawaii yes hawaii the loco moco when you
think of a hawaiian burger unfortunately
i think you're probably thinking of
pineapples you're thinking of ham
are you ready for this one it wasn't
even invented in hawaii the pineapple on
a burger was actually
started in ontario canada
not kidding in canada not hawaii a real
homegrown
hawaiian burger is unquestionably the
loco moco it's actually not even really
a hamburger i like to include it in the
hamburger family there are four elements
to a loco moco it's a bed of rice on a
plate
the hamburger patty on top of that
covered in brown gravy and then there is
a fried egg on top
basically i'm making a smash burger on a
flat top
a little bit of salt
i like making fried onion burgers so i'm
actually adding onions to the burger the
same way they would have done it in
oklahoma this burger was actually
invented by a football team and i think
you probably understand why a lot of
protein here
you want to make sure you fry an egg
perfectly you have to have a runny yolk
okay now the burger's done burger
on to rice now gravy so now we have rice
hamburger patty gravy and now the fried
egg goes on top this is on fire hang on
okay fried egg on top ah
oh look at that
wait over here here get a shot of that
get in there
[Music]
oh
a little hot sauce would work
illocomoco
oh
that's [ __ ] good
[Laughter]
we're going all the way back to the turn
of the century that's right
121 years ago
when louie's lunch in new haven
connecticut made one of the very first
hamburger sandwiches in america
ever for those interested in hamburger
history a trip to louie's lunch to get
an original hamburger sandwich is an
absolute must i'm going to attempt to
faithfully recreate the hamburger
sandwich from louie's lunch using
similar historic equipment and it starts
with this
this is a vertical broiler
if you've been to louie's lunch you've
seen the upright broilers that are the
center piece of the restaurant
the flames actually come at whatever
you're cooking from the sides so we're
going to form a patty
give it some slapping
[Music]
i'm gonna put this into
my salmon grill yeah up there okay i'm
gonna take a piece of onion
and put it on the patty just like that
and into
our upright broiler it goes
to cut
very exciting very important remember
that the hamburger sandwich at louie's
lunch pre-dates the bun the classic
hamburger bun by over 20 years by two
decades they use toast well good good
they realized they couldn't put cheese
on this thing clearly they started to
use a processed cheese spread here it is
on to okay onto the toast only condiment
you can get other than cheese and onion
is a slice of tomato another piece of
toast where is it over here here we go
they basically cut this in half just
like that
and there you have it
the original
hamburger sandwich from louie's lunch
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh wow
this is accurate that is literally as
accurate as it gets
wow
it is my mission to preserve the
american hamburger in all of its forms
[Music]
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there yeah watch
more episodes right here